Hello Freak bitches.
People saying like,
why does Mike Tyson,
he,
first of all,
he's a fighter.
He's not a tennis player,
but Mike was a wild boy and to hang out with him,
you could understand like he was the biggest person on the planet and he had the
demons.
You know what I'm saying?
Everybody's fun too.
Cause it,
cause you see them in a club and he sees,
he sees some girls.
You mean hi.
How are you doing?
You like BMWs when girls do that,
what do you like?
You like BMW,
like cod.
You like BMWs and crazy.
He would take the girls out and go get a BMW.
I mean,
he was at crazy,
you know what I'm saying?
Just saying,
come on,
let's look at the beer.
And we open up the BMW dealership,
but he was wild.
But I say just like,
how are we saying off the here I'm going into my garage and there's two guys,
a little guy like this and a tall guy.
The little guy goes,
Yo Yo,
it's like this all the time,
be.
I said,
yeah,
who are you?
He says,
oh,
we didn't have to,
my name is Farrell.
I said,
yeah,
I'm going to hurt you.
That's how long ago this was.
Wow.
So he's like,
can I,
I said,
just go in and have it,
have a great time.
Uh,
there was another guy standing on the wall,
green jacket,
like a green little jumpsuit.
Nobody's talking to him.
Guess who was who?
Jay Z.
Nobody knew.
I said,
what's up man?
He's just a great party.
So crazy.
But you know,
no one knows.
But,
and now the way I got into the music,
however,
is that all these different parties was going on and I would have like different
musical people leave me music in my little studio that I built.
I went and got this great studio built in the back of my house.
And so one day comes,
this kid backpack on jaws busted.
Who is it?
Oh,
it's Kanye.
his John's busted from my car accident,
right.
Kanya and walks in and I said,
who's that?
They said,
all,
they said,
new my fucking Kanye man.
He bout to beat the shit.
I said,
what are you do?
Well,
he produces,
but he also wrapped.
I said,
well,
anybody come to my house?
They got to perform.
So I said,
Yo man,
they say,
you know,
you rappers it,
he wrapped the most incredible free.
I don't know if it was free,
it wasn't current.
I said,
I don't know why you aren't famous.
He did it with a broken jaw.
He had a little bro,
little jobs,
a little swollen.
I don't think it was broken,
but it was a little swollen cause it wasn't too long after that accident that he
had.
Right.
And then he goes,
ah,
I,
I got a Song Dad,
dad,
you or you'll be cut on.
Ah,
I got the song.
I know you could kill it.
I was like me.
So goofy face.
If I read all the comments,
I'll never try another,
you know,
I got a movie that we just a shot for little or nothing called all star weekend.
And it,
the jokes are like all the way out there,
you know?
And,
and it's,
I got everybody in it,
you know,
and we're all taking,
we all play different characters.
Like I play a white racist,
white racist cop.
And how do you do that?
I'll show,
I'll show it to you.
I'll grab,
I'll grab the thing and show to you.
But it's a,
they,
uh,
Robert Downey jr plays a Mexican.
I called,
I said,
listen,
I need you to play a Mexican.
He says,
dude,
here's the deal.
Sure.
Fuck it.
Why not?
Sure.
Of course.
Mexican,
whatever it back.
I had a,
um,
a bee tea party,
right?
3000 people at my house counted Jesus.
People at the gate,
you know,
trying to get in is,
and as I looked through the party,
there's Floyd Mayweather all time j box.
We'll start baby,
I'll talk to you.
You got to waste party.
I love you,
but you don't got to,
got to fight coming and you,
you know,
so there's Florida's Fed Joe,
this little Kim is on stage performing and I don't want to put everything out
there that he does.
He's super,
super competitive.
That's what's amazing.
But he also understands that,
yeah,
j Fox,
I understand what's going on.
Your autonomy.
They,
they,
they want me to fall j Fox.
But that's what keeps me competitive.
That's what I,
you know,
all the time,
easily work,
light work.
So he will sit at my crib and speak for like hours.
Okay.
Yeah.
But he also understands that yeah.
J Fox on understanding what's going on,
you know,
autonomy.
They want me to fall j Fox.
But that's what keeps me competitive.
That's what I,
you know,
all the time.
Easy work,
light work.
So he will sit at my crib and speak for like hours.
Okay.